things seem to be heating up between
Pete Davidson and Margaret Kweli the
rumored couple was spotted in Venice
Italy on Monday during the 2019 Venice
Film Festival where Margaret premiered
her flick Seberg the two looked cutest
can be holding hands and smiling
ear-to-ear
the 24-year old actress looked chic in a
tea-length dress and white heeled
sandals Pete kept it cash for the outing
rocking a baseball hat a graphic t-shirt
basketball shorts and sneakers
this Italian PDA filled sighting comes
after the two were spotted leaving a
Venice hotel together rumors of a
romance between the 25 year old Saturday
Night Live star and Margaret who
recently starred in Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood began last week and hit a peak
at her Venice premiere at the event
Margaret sat next to her co-star Anthony
Mackie but Pete was seen sitting
directly behind his rumored girlfriend
and get this margaret is Andie
McDowell's daughter how exciting is it
for you to watch her achieve so much
success in in this crazy industry she's
always been an amazing creature in my
life I just try to stay out of her way
she's very ambitious she was a really
hard-working as a child for wanting to
be a professional dancer and she's you
know always expected excellence of
herself she has previously been linked
to musician NAT Wolff and director Cary
Fukunaga as for Pete's past
relationships he was last linked to Kate
Beckinsale a source previously told et
that they are quote still friends but
are not on romantic terms then of course
there's this
[Music]
prior to his time with Kate
Pete got engaged - thank you next singer
Ariana Grande after less than a month of
dating before calling it off just a few
months later
[Music]